one must earn everything they acquire in
life life may be free but living is not
and therefore we all must work for it
working is essential in life but what's
important is what kind of work is
essential to you working is needed for
survival and the acquisition of personal
luxuries but you must not only look at
work in terms of what it can give you
you must also consider what your work
can give the world you must consider the
world as a massive and intricate puzzle
that your on individual piece of find
out what piece you are where it fits to
help complete the puzzles image look
inward admit to yourself what it is that
you possess what it is that you are good
at and enjoy what the world needs for
you this is the work that we each must
dedicate ourselves to in terms of self
purpose in life it is unlikely that
anyone has a divine destiny but it is
likely that life works itself out
through the maze of the world in order
to accomplish the purpose you encode
into your subconscious work towards
developing their purpose and fearlessly
act on its behalf the manifestation of
your purpose starts with undivided
belief in it and ends with undivided
attention towards it to paraphrase
American transcendentalist Ralph Waldo
Emerson
if a man has failed it is because he has
only dreamt and never worked it is the
pairing of dreaming and working that
provides a person with the ability to
pull dreams out of dream world and into
the real world
like a newborn baby dreams cannot
initially walk on their own he was first
carried must be patient and careful soon
they will learn to walk and soon they
will grow strong and powerful by
contributing honestly and wholeheartedly
what it is that you have for the world
you transform work into vitality and
wonder it becomes Mutual for you the
individual and the world the collective
working does not have to be a
debilitating thing can be energizing and
satisfying thing look for and uncover
what fits your unique self and follow it
to the end of the world if done properly
you will be compensated
[Music]